elle s'affiche partout les cadeaux de
noël à peine déballés
les ventes privées prennent le relais
chez les commerçants franchisés à tous
les coups chez les autres il reste
encore quelques résistants le lendemain
de noël seuls des les produits que les
clients viennent offrir pour les fêtes
je trouve ça un petit peu se moquer du
client d'autres sont même carrément en
colère contre ces soldes déguisées on
n'attend plus rien de ces soldes voilà
tout est dit était réduite à quatre
semaines mais en réalité si elle
n'existait plus ça serait pareil tout à
fait ça c'est nos soldes pas de soldes
pas d'avenir pour le commerce 10 les
plus pessimistes qui ne retrouvent plus
leurs marques dans ce système bouleversé
par le commerce en ligne et les
promotions continues
le principe même des sols de deux fois
par an n'a plus beaucoup de sens les dix
premières années où j'ai ouvert
je vous cite je vous assure qu'on
faisait nos soldes jusqu'au dernier jour
on avait du monde
on travaille est hyper bien après ça ça
un petit peu étouffé maintenant c'est
une semaine les gens tout moment vous
vous ouvrez commencé à faire une
collection pour seul et des 30% des 40%
donc les gens ils ont plus de notion du
prix ici pourquoi acheter plein pot
quand on peut acheter toute l'année en
solde et même ceux qui suivent les
consignes de leur enseigne reconnaissent
que les ventes privées ont pris le pas
sur les remises pour tous là ça permet
aux gens qui sont en vacances de voilà
après noël de faire leurs achats
ça tue un peu les soldes quand même un
petit peu mais c'est derrière après oui
pour le premier jour des soldes
on va il ya moins de choix c'est vrai
que maintenant il faut profiter des
ventes privées pour pour faire le plein
à moindre coût comme ses clients en
vacances à besançon mais vivant au
danemark dans leur pays de résidence
les soldes privées sont général est
encore plus précoce que chez nous ils le
font juste avant noël
m donc voilà avant noël ou et quelques
jours avant noël pour le rush final pour
être sûr d'écouler le plus possible
le pire est donc peut-être encore à
venir pour les commerçants les clients
eux ont déjà pris l'habitude de ce
nouveau rendez vous